the Joe Rogan experience um do you know
who butcher Brown is oh yeah we got to
have the hours yeah whose butcher Brown
I think it's for seams John he's a
doctor that did a bunch of like
unlicensed sex change surgeries in like
garages hotels he's on murder pedia
if Jamie wants to what's your Brown Wow
so he did unlicensed sex change
operations and people died from it yeah
while he is so minimal eating raw hotdog
extreme coffee raw hot dogs
it's was eatin hot dogs and cutting off
dicks you're not worried they're
everything keep going bro that's the
most ridiculous thing I've ever heard he
was eating raw hotdogs and cutting off
dicks that's what he does man while
drinking dr. pepper and how many people
did he I think was almost I mean it was
hundreds there's a lot like a detailed
descriptive article bit did it work on
anybody did everybody die you got to
read it if you watch head and read that
why did you auto all the things to curse
me with but he's gonna change dr.
America's worst doctor well ever I think
ever once you read it Krazy Glue that
you see the guy's picture and you're
like yep let me see the picture Jimmy he
silicone wherever you want it for like
200 bucks you know and then just like
what caulk like so come on get up with
Krazy Glue and tell you to lay down flat
for two days
oh my god but he's had a lot of business
I'm not sure I found it work on anybody
imagine if you like made one bomb ass
like that it's great job it came out
great once and he's like I'm just
chasing that dragon every time I'm
trying to get one time I nailed it we
got here well I don't mind a [ __ ] in
this lady's ass cheeks to the dude it
helped a man to look better
most the time it looks like a disaster
oh you found them yeah see what butcher
bob looks like I don't like to judge
people based on a period but
oh my God look at the frown on his face
he's a caricature that's a smile
I would not assume that guy's friendly
homicide self-appointed sex change
specialist practicing medicine without a
license oh he didn't even have a license
yeah damn it they should make a movie
about this guy and live Bryan Cranston
sentenced to 15 years to life died in
prison in 2010 that he has a funny thing
is you read in here that there's another
guy that's his competition that's the
second worst doctor or debatable but it
was this guy real doctor now he was a
said self-appointed right so I don't
know anybody does that mean I thought he
had like a some sort of a military
thyroids everything self-appointed sex
change specialist no hundreds of
operations you know don't do that for
any gay doctor it's his place was called
what was it called like the room of
dream born into a strict Mormon family
Brown was a gifted child oh boy how many
[ __ ] disaster start out with that
sentence born into a strict Mormon
family Brown was a gifted child that's
the open parts of a novel that it was
terribly wrong he had a miniaturization
technique for clitoris
he took the patient's penis and turned
into a clitoris apparently guaranteeing
his clients full sexual pleasure he
presented his work in the 1973 medical
conference where his technique earned
him the respect of some of the world's
most famous surgeons without surgical
qualifications Brown had to perform his
operations the most unlikely in
inappropriate locations one early
patient remembers going to his office
assuming he would do a checkup
but awoke from the anesthetic to
discover that he had operated in the
office he turned his garage into an
operating theater and the more
operations he did the further his
standard slips oh my god despite the
concerns of his peers many of Brown's
patients appeared to be happy that's
like if you bought a really small book
it would end right there
one of his early patients Elizabeth had
been delighted with her surgery and your
later things started to go wrong
her vagina started to tighten and close
up you wanted it tight Brown was
abandoning his patients and leaving them
to other surgeons like dr. Jack Fisher
to pick up the pieces he says it's hard
to imagine anyone worse than John Brown
he didn't care much for any evaluating
his patients before surgery or for
post-operative care he was totally
focused on the technical procedure
itself and he didn't do that very well
Jesus Christ man putting some good [ __ ]
out in the world have you done this to
him buddy right there yeah you got a do
head this then watch a shocking buck
Johnson buck and buck and why do I not
want to look what the [ __ ] you do sure
play games
[Applause]